1950s and 60s marketing the biggest
brands in the world ran a lot of
newspaper locally and the creative in
the newspaper was contextual to the
market they were running the newspaper
for and then they would run a national
campaign based on what they were doing
in the newspapers
all I'm doing is treating social media
like local newspapers and like local
radio but I have better data than they
did back then which then makes our
campaign work much stronger because
we've mitigated the risk because we've
gotten a consumer affirmation and in the
last three years social media has gotten
such strong algorithms because of tick
tock now everyone that I have really
clean data